hi I'm Alison Brie yeah I'm Marc Maron
and we're doing a wire autocompletes
interviewed autocomplete oh is you wait
okay Marc Maron do you know what we're
doing I'm hosting this interview she's
on top of it do you want me I'll read
them and then I'm supposed to answer
them now mm brie and dave franco meet we
were introduced by a mutual friend at
Mardi Gras in New Orleans Marty that's
all you need to know Wow were you drunk
yeah okay didn't Alison Brie didn't
Alison Brie balloons
I did not doesn't mean that wait I did
not balloons no because I can make
balloon animals I actually do think I
know what this is related to because I
used to work as a clown for kids
birthday parties in my youth and I can
make balloon animals didn't Alison Brie
wrap yeah
I've wrapped yeah I used to rap on
community because I worked with Donald
Glover aka childish gambino who was
always making like real amazing music so
I would jokingly rap a lot and then
people wanted to make me rap all the
time similarly to the balloon animal
thing and I had to draw a line I've done
it a million you'll find it maybe you
could do something integrating the two
like Raph and my job didn't Alison Brie
English I did do an English accent in
the movie The Five Year Engagement
I played emily Blunt's sister did you
get a teaching tools that you listen to
in your car and you were driving around
going hello
exactly okay didn't Alison Brie Elmo
impression also true also from the
five-year engagement in one scene we
have like a very serious conversation
while doing Elmo and Cookie Monster
respectively what was the preparation I
actually don't know Elmo is what got me
the part because I went to the table
read for the movie not having been cast
officially and Elmo brought the house
down
I don't really remember yeah English
accent I also remembered know that Judd
Apatow thought I actually was British
after that it was like wow you've really
never seen my other work maybe he
thought I was doing an amazing American
accent I think Mad Men this is what I'm
just gonna turn into my dad who is the
lady in the skating movie Margot Robbie
I didn't know she was an American she's
not American where's she Australia
Australia Australia Margot Robbie looks
like the tables have turned Marc Maron
no boy is Marc Maron drumroll please is
Marc Maron podcast I am oh I am podcast
Wow I host a podcast I get it twice a
week I interview celebrities like Alison
Brie and writers and musicians I've
interviewed people like Neil Young and
President Barack Obama so I was counting
the seconds to see how long till you
said Barack Obama I don't I don't put
that one right up front
I'll throw like Randy Newman in there
you'll Wanda Sykes then I'll throw in
Obama you put it up front is Marc Maron
married it's it's a common mistake he's
not being married I've been married
twice I'm not there now that current but
I'm with somebody I think she'd get
married if I would bring it out good
space to talk about that I've been
married twice is there a point to
another one I've said this to her okay
too much let's move on where is Marc
Maron from I'm genetically New Jersey I
was born in New Jersey and then I moved
to Alaska for a couple years then New
Mexico I think is where I did the
primary growing up Albuquerque oh
there's more and the first thing that
comes up is Ward what Alison Brie she's
yeah up to Oh talk about the show season
two
shooting the show glow season - yeah is
Alison Brie related to the Laura Marano
who's Laura Marano I have no idea uh and
we're not related I don't think I've
never done 23andme maybe if I did I
would never I want to do that that means
UK because I think I'm thinking I have
Viking in me okay
is alison brie single no sorry you guys
know she's married to Davy and the least
amount of single come on yeah
get up to speed hello who does Alison
Brie look like oh you know I get Natalie
Imbruglia more than anything since I was
15 and still when my hair is short again
yeah I think since I saw you do the
Audrey Hepburn
you know impression yeah I think that
it's a hydrate heparin thing but no one
remembers her I'm not sure I do but I
know who she is I don't have a long
history of balloon animals and rapping
on camera where is Marc Maron's house
I'm not gonna tell you where it is smart
so you don't come over to my house just
linger looking at it there's not many of
you but you know who you are I get why
people ask this because I feel like on
your podcast one of the number one
things people comment on is where am I
yeah are you gonna murder me right did
that wait a minute that you know what is
Marc Maron God people really are the
reason I know why this happens is
because it's on there that you can just
Google my old address and it just comes
up I'm glad you moved I know I moved in
but now this is gonna cause problems now
someone out there is gonna take it upon
themselves to think I think she bought
into trust you can hide if don't do it
don't do it don't do it I mean that guy
living I was right down the street from
Alison where did
Marc Maron go to college I went to a
small liberal arts college for
middle-class Jewish kids for one year
and then ice transferred to a slightly
better college what was the name of
these colleges the first one was Curry
College in Milton Massachusetts but they
let people like me and you know people
were like it no and a good at
college okay I do I do and then I
transferred to Boston University I did
five years undergrad and it really paid
off
although Curry College sounds a little
made-up it was real it was a real place
okay why would I say that why would I
make up with a little school I went does
Alison Brie have an Instagram yes at
Alison Brie does Alison Brie have yes an
older sister Lauren can Alison Brie
definitely I used to have a cover band
with my friends called the girls what
was your most popular cover maybe rich
girl by hollow notes
oh just dance kind of why
Marc Maron why why does Marc Maron hate
everyone
I don't think I hate everyone I think
that I'm cranky sometimes and at times
of resentful of other people's things
but that is past because I have my own
things now why does Marc Maron save
boomer lives boomer was a cat that I had
years ago that disappeared it was
traumatic and it became sort of this
rallying cry at the end of my podcast as
a sort of homage to my my missing cat we
never know what happened to him I like
to think that he lived he became mythic
how to contact Marc Maron people really
want to get to you - be my number it's
nine one seven
no Marc no now they know that that is
you're gonna get money or how tall Marc
Maron I believe I'm still 511 though I
am getting older which might I might
shrink a little how to watch
Marc Maron more later that was a special
I did for the very popular cable outlet
called epics do you have it yeah you
know No Deal if you think you do that
was the problem you can get more later
on iTunes how long are we doing this is
you heard it here first
thank you for your time